who all uh production-wise do we have on
Triple S obviously uh DJ Paul Alchemist
obviously Alchemist Mad Lib
that's crazy I got both of them on the
DJ Parts
um
sheesh uh seven Thomas boy Wanda
um
damn Yeah Boy Wonder for show we got
some other [ __ ] that we did that didn't
we just we did so many records we just I
just couldn't fit them all but we gonna
do some more [ __ ] uh who else uh
produced on this album uh
man damn
why is my mind going blank right now but
you know shout out to everybody that
produced on the album man I'm tripping
right now I think I smoked the wrong
thing but
you you get the idea yeah I mean have an
alchemist and Mad Libs important yeah
yeah both of them on the major come on
man definitely you know what I'm saying
so important to the your career both of
those guys
oh I'm sorry kaytranada kaytranada
um
who else
oh I gotta think about it man God damn
man you caught me off guard let me look
at my phone have you guys already uh
kicked the idea around to doing Alfredo
too
oh
what's funny you say that but I just
told you that every time I do an album I
feel like it's so it's I might not do
another one I got a lot of stuff to do
like man bro this whole process
recording the album I barely got to see
my kids a lot you know I mean touring
like man I'm ready I'm really ready to
just chill dog I don't know if I can go
through the process or recording the
album no more really I don't know if I
can after this I mean I feel like this
probably is this again like you said
this is one of my best albums you know I
mean and I feel and like I said I feel
like that every time I do one so I'm
like damn
man you know I'll be like have a topic
you listen you did two with Mad Lib I
feel like it's only right you do two
with Alchemist
I totally agree with you yeah but
you know I don't know man I just don't
know if I want to do another album right
now do you feel like you've kind of also
helped like kick off the trend of doing
like the fool because I feel like I see
people doing like like I feel like you
know the whole locking in with a
producer I think that I do that the best
you know I mean out of uh anybody
because pinata was what 2014 right right
right I think I do that the best I think
uh Rock Marciano just did that with
Alchemist and that was tight great album
yeah that was tight great album shout
out to rock Marcy I was supposed to do
something with rock with timing and
everything I like him yeah definitely I
love Rockmart he's incredible
um
Peace I mean if it had you know maybe we
can make that happen I love Alchemist
that's like my brother so we flirt with
the idea all the time you know what I'm
saying and if I was to make another if I
was to do another album it would be that
one yeah you know what I mean so if
there is another album after Triple S
Alfredo too yeah maybe maybe I don't
know man I want to record right now but
I just want to go get a boat that's fair
you know what I'm saying go go I want
you work on this variety show that you
just thought yeah I got so I got the
variety show I got a couple films I got
like three movies I just signed on to do
like she was like for real like so I'm
like I really I don't know if I got I
really don't know you might have time I
might not have time to do another album
right now though for like five years
like for real I got so much stuff going
up man my kids getting bigger dog you
know what I'm saying they like it's you
know they they need me to be around a
lot right now for sure you know I kind
of gotta after I do all of this triple
that stuff you know I kind of gotta like
sit down for a little bit sit down and
go into dad mode for a minute because
you know I deprived them of a lot of
time the past two years because I had to
like
get where I wanted to be career-wise so
that I can you know continue to provide
for them for life you know